[Musique]
on a quand même un taux de chômage qui
est autour de 10% on a des salaires qui
sont moins extrêmement compris mais
depuis un certain nombre d'années les
taux d'utilisation des entreprises sont
bien dans sa des capacités productives
donc pour moi le risque aujourd'hui
davantage la déflation que l'inflation
quant à la proposition de monsieur
pelletier sur le sur le papier ça peut
paraître sympathique mais en pratique ça
revient à dire aux salariés que ils vont
payer leur augmentation avec leurs
propres revenus 10 cm donc ça veut dire
concrètement que on prend leur droit à
la retraite à la sécu caetera et c'est
avec ça qu'ils vont payer leur propre
augmentation et en plus c'est une
proposition qui est totalement uniforme
et donc une fois de plus va profiter à
celles et à ceux qui sont tout en haut
de l'échelle des salaires
donc je ne suis pas convaincu que s'il
hausses de salaires il doit y avoir elle
doit être de 20 % et surtout uniforme
sur tout les chefs des salaires décents
provoquerait un choc d'importation ça
profiterait assez peu en fait autant ps
français donc ça déjà assez
catastrophique ça causerait balance
commerciale et puis ça provoquerait
aussi de la relation parce que
actuellement la demande
enfin l'offre au niveau mondial ne
n'arrive pas à satisfaire la demande il
ya des pannes de semi conducteurs il ya
des il ya il ya des conditions au tome
du français qui arrêtent des chaînes de
montage parce qu'ils manquent de semi
conducteurs dont hop dans ce cadre-là
augmenter les salaires de 20%
ça ferait de l'inflation et des
importations et ça n'apporterait pas
grand chose à l'économie française
la solution pour pouvoir augmenter de
façon durable et celles pouvoir d'achat
des français dans les années qui
viennent c'est de diminuer le poids de
la dépense publique le poids des impôts
et des taxes qui pèsent sur l'économie
est comme ça on va pouvoir retrouver
économie qui sera plus oxygéné on va
dire on va pouvoir les industriels
essaient de localiser certaine pour
commencer à revenir et c'est de cette
façon là pour pouvoir servir des
meilleurs salaires du pouvoir d'achat et
diminuer le chômage en france voilà
[Musique]
moi j'y suis favorable à cette à cette
transaction taxe sur les transactions
financières le problème c'est que c'est
un vieux serpent de mer qui n'a jamais
été l'exemple à ce monsieur chirac en
avait parlé
c'est devenu une simple taxe sur les
billets d'avion
donc si la taxe sur les transactions
financières c'est quelque chose qui
vient taxer les transactions à la nano
secondes
j'en suis totalement d'accord si c'est
pour taxer l'investissement à deux ans
ou à trois ans j'y suis j'en suis
beaucoup moins d'accord donc il faudrait
qu il précise qu est-ce qui veut taxer
et les souks elle sous quelles
conditions s'il s'agit de ralentir le
rythme effréné de ces transactions
financières et de comment dit on de
mettre un grain de sable dans les
rouages de la finance internationale
comme le disait monsieur tobin qui avait
proposé sa dans les années soixante dix
j'en serais d'accord mais 20% de hausse
uniforme des salaires ça n'a aucun sens
et benoît en pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui sont les besoins pouvoir
d'achat pour ceux qui sont en bas de
l'échelle sociale
donc si on veut vraiment que ce soit
efficace une augmentation des salaires
il faut commencer par le smic ce qui
provoquerait une hausse des revenus en
voisinage du smic
en plus les cotisations sociales il faut
bien comprendre c'est du salaire différé
sébastien bruno mettre une taxe de 2%
sur les achats électroniques et cdo sur
le commerce électronique en contact sur
le commerce électronique alors pourquoi
parce que ya pas qu amazon com profite
il ya aussi c'est d'abord avant tout les
entreprises françaises qui sont présents
sur commerce électronique dans pourquoi
leur taper dessus
et puis 2 % sur les transactions
financières ça paraît comme ça bien
parce qu'on se dit on va taper sur la
spéculation h un bon il faut comprendre
que en fait c'est une taxe sur l'épargné
mais les transactions financières c'est
font face un impôt et taxe aussi élevé
et pour tout simplement se faire dans
d'autres pays parce que les transactions
financières c'est quelque chose de très
mobile donc penser qu'on peut retirer
490 milliards d'euros d'une taxe sur les
transactions financières c'est
complètement aberrant c'est c'est ça
qu'il faut et ignare en économie pour
pouvoir affirmer une chose pareil c'est
pas possible c'est un tel niveau ça
ferait fuir les toutous les trending ne
s'est pas d'abord défendre
trading à haute fréquence mais je veux
dire celui qui se fait en france et il
partira étrangers parce que ce serait
bientôt rentable de le faire voilà pour
la ligue
donc c'est complètement aberrant de
proposer des chiffres comme ça en disant
bien au wat et 20 % de salaire en plus
pour les gens comme ça du jour au
lendemain c'est c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi c'est la fecq
économie c'est vraiment c'est pas
sérieux du tout surtout que ça fait
l'impasse sur pour moi le problème
principal le problème de base qu'il
faudra régler qui est la diminution de
la dépense publique en france parce
qu'on a déjà un taux de prélèvements
obligatoires qui est le plus élevé des
pays de l'osce et des hommes et ça ça
pèse sur l'économie ça perce sur les
salaires sa place à pouvoir d'achat
s'appelle sur les industries c'est en
partie pour ça que les sept délocalisent
évidemment sur ce point nous sommes dans
des accords nous serions en accord si on
était au plein emploi
2 % de chômage et puis dans une
situation fantastique avec 5 ou 6% de
croissance
quelqu'un on pourrait effectivement
réfléchir à une diminution des dépenses
publiques
on est en train de nous dire que la
voiture n'avance pas et perd donc
continuons d'avancer sur les freins et
si elle n'avance toujours pas envolée
roues non effectivement quand on se
rendit cette vitesse on reparlera de
d'appuyer sur le frein